ambassador Bill Taylor will be the first
witness to testify when the House
Intelligence Committee starts holding
public hearings on impeachment next week
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy
what's the point of these witnesses
testifying in public if their
closed-door testimony has already been
made available well Anthony one Democrat
put it to me like this ultimately the
jury here is the American public they're
the ones who need to be convinced the
polls show that currently the public is
split 50-50 on impeachment and removal
so Democrats have gathered all the
evidence now they need to lay it out for
the jury in the most compelling way and
they're starting with the people they
believe are their most compelling
witnesses non-partisan decades of
experience all of them very well-spoken
witnesses - or victims of this
back-channel diplomacy that they say ran
counter to Americans in America's
interest and was only in the president's
interest
Nancy what comes after these public
hearings and do we know how long they're
gonna last well the last at least a
couple of weeks then the House
Intelligence Committee would transfer
all of the evidence it's gathered to the
House Judiciary Committee which would
draw up and debate actual articles of
impeachment maybe hold its own hearings
and then if a vote is successful in
judiciary it all goes to the full House
of Representatives for a straight
majority vote on those articles of
impeachment if it passes there it would
then go to a Senate for a trial and then
a two-thirds vote on removing the
president from office Nancy Cordes Thank
You Nancy